oh yeah lots of fun with cars Rocky and
speaking of fun this weekend in Mesquite
is the super run car show which is
brought to you by Casablanca Resort and
Casino the sponsors of this segment I've
got Christian he is the captain of fun
up there in Mesquite we're so excited
the car show is back absolutely we had
super run this weekend the Casablanca
Resort again for over 700 cars up there
this weekend so if you're a car fan you
gotta get to the Casablanca this weekend
it's a blast and the cars start showing
on Friday yeah we're gonna be showing
off Friday Saturday and Sunday so show
and shine uh so many great things to do
with this show but the people that come
up is free to the public to attend and
they can vote for their favorite car
while they're up there because you have
this is a 1939 that we're looking at you
guys have a lot of awards that happen up
there as well we do we have over 250
awards that we're gonna give away that
weekend this weekend and over fifteen
thousand dollars in cash and prizes for
these car owners it's such a blast going
to land spin around because I want you
to see right there that's a 2014 Mustang
the black car on your right a 5-0 which
the gentleman won at Barrett Jackson and
then to the left we have a 1981 Corvette
what kind of cars are be after all kinds
of different muscle cars Classics less
than anything about super run is you're
you're open to all makes and models so
you're going to see Rat Rods you see
Classics you see muscle cars you can see
Customs so if you're a car fan you're
gonna see every kind of car underneath
the Sun up at the cost of walking I'm a
huge car fan it's something I love about
your car show there in Mesquite is that
you get cars coming up from Las Vegas
Virginia cars coming down from Denver
from Salt Lake City from all over the
place absolutely the whole region comes
down to Mesquite for the super run car
show and with over 700 cars you're going
to see cars from all over the all over
the west coast and uh they all come to
Mesquite because we put on a great car
show it's a free event sir what year is
your vehicle 1957 Pontiac 1957 Pontiac
it is gorgeous it's a stunning car your
car show is very Instagram worthy I love
going up there thousands of great
pictures you can take talk to you about
the rooms though because you should make
a weekend out of this absolutely we
still have some rooms available get them
fast because we're gonna the a lot of
cars are coming up a lot of people so
make sure you book your room at
casablancareesort.com and grab a room
and enjoy a great car show this weekend
you get to see all these beautiful cars
the other great theme about the show is
you can see what's underneath the hood
we have open header cruises we have
burnout competitions we have roaring
engine competitions your car fan you're
going to see everything up at the
superunk car show and what I love about
your car show is all the car owners are
hanging out by their cars and car owners
love talking about their vehicles what
year is your Corvette has a C5 98 have
you had it since 98 uh no no it's uh
you're kind of gathering as you go yeah
yeah exactly how many cars do you have
uh I've got four yeah that's what I love
about car people how many cars do you
have it's not one it's two three four
five that's right is there gonna be any
entertainment I remember last year
there's a DJ playing some music yeah
we're gonna DJ's playing all the show
and sign Lots all weekend long so grab
the family coming up again free to the
public get the vote for your favorite
car and you're gonna see all these
Beauties up in Mesquite this weekend so
get to the Casablanca this weekend I
love it the website real fast Christian
go to casablancareort.com to book your
room and go to super run.com for all the
info on the car show I will see you
there this weekend we look forward to it
it's gonna be a blast Rocky we'll send
it back to you thank you JC and thank
you again to Casa Resort for sponsoring
that segment for more information just
call 1-877 getaway or visit
casablancaresort.com